[Applaus]
was ist denn hier los in einer halben
stunde kommen die ersten gäste und hier
ist noch nichts dekoriert
das müsste eigentlich schon längst alles
erledigt diese karnevalsfete ist mein
einstand in die münchner party sehen da
in die pose bussi gesellschaft oder wie
hier das schicke die adeba de ganz genau
und wir sind ein junges aufstrebendes
start up unternehmen und müssen uns
positionieren dein kostüm zum beispiel
das finde ich super spitze das motto ist
20er jahre und du gehst als edelnutte
das ist anders das ist provokant das
sind wie was für ein motto was der note
ich habe meine kostüme gar nicht an
als wüsstest du den verkleidet wer das
sieht man doch the great gatsby sah er
aus wie carsten maschmeyer maschmeyer
naja hauptsache mit geld oder aber sag
mal wo ist denn die deko es nicht ruhig
in der champagne wo sind die canapés und
wo ist eigentlich der eventmanager
von der fessel management
das bamberger fans das ist der
citymanager ich habe gesagt wir brauchen
einen eventmanager das ist doch nur der
hausmeister wo hast du so nur
hausmeister aus was ist das schönste
beruf von der ganzen welt durchaus drin
haus und meister es wirklich und sie
organisieren meine karnevalsfete sophie
sag mir bitte dass das nicht wahr ist ja
wie hinkommen müssen in bayern mit vom
fasching und für die faschingsfeier ist
alles da was man braucht und wo ist der
champagner dusche
das heiße getränke sind exportbier
export wie ist nämlich der champagner
und bier
aber das ist doch nur bier wir brauchen
wir brauchen split wir brauchen wodka
und champagner lasst das von einem
fachmann sagen niemals zueinander sache
des kriegs
[Applaus]
das kann doch auf meiner steht bin nicht
nur exportbier anbieten
august recht mein gott bin jetzt habe
ich es weiß wir vergessen das glaube ich
nicht ich habe in meinem ganzen leben
noch nie ein bier vergessen das ist doch
mein lebensmotto mein eigenes tempo
bleibt zurück
wolltest du dich nicht auch um die
kostüme gemeint ist für dich und der
wird der ist für sich was ist jetzt
es ist sozusagen in universal kosten
das passt immer schlicht einfach und
doch geschmacklos also jetzt reicht's
aber ich habe einen ruf als münchner
party könig aufzubauen und sie
verkleiden mir hier die leute als als
hausmeister sagt man du warst ja ich
jedenfalls nicht
wen hast du eigentlich für uns als show
sprach's doch von einem hochkaräter halt
dich fest
ich habe meine beziehungen spielen
lassen und ich habe den michael
mittermeier wind bekommen nein das ist
ja wunderbar den mieter mensch da
brauchen wir unbedingt blumen ich möchte
den mieter unbedingt blumen überreichen
aber es ja die jury nun zur baumberger
immer im kabuff draußen müssen irgendwo
sagt oder kaktus im raum locken
jetzt lassen sie mal schön sein das
macht mich selber ich bin gleich wieder
da
ja
[Applaus]
schön dass du da bist halt nicht
wirklich sehr dass es geklappt hat
für die azubis diese komik nicht so
bescheiden
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
aber spaß beiseite
da wusste ich denke die tricks geht es
aber kein bier ist nicht echt was draus
machen wir folgen die schale her dort
und zimmermann auslösen
schade dass du schwimmst 0
[Musik]
bei der rückfahrt so ist er eher scheu
so scheu fast schon nicht vor
so kunz
was ist da wie von der schwarz weißen
die berichtet über die angesagtesten
party sind ganz münchen sowie grüßte was
für eine ehre mensch toll siehst du aus
in einem dirndl sowieso ein richtig
fesches madl ich stehe zur zeit total
auch alles heimatverbundene barriere
aber hier ist ja gar nichts dekoriert
feiert er denn gar nicht verschickt doch
betrachten uns gehen nur genau dasselbe
wie du wir machen man hat es einfach ist
also heimatverbunden barriere ridge also
ganz künftig so richtig zünftig werz wir
haben auch extra das gute exportbier
eingekauft das find ich klasse
verbundenheit mit der bayerischen
tradition einfach bodenständig oder
wieder bayer sagt gib entwickeln apropos
simpel
das ist unser ident manager erich echter
bayern so richtig authentisch so richtig
ehrlich auch genau was er will hobby
vergessen
aber ich werde da kein befehl keine
sorge im bw ist bestellen muss jede
sekunde ein treffen haben beim metzger
mit einem nebenzimmer bresser comics
roten und weißen durch durch für jeden
was dabei
ich liebe vegan und du brauchst du keine
angst im preis sorgt kommt werden die so
schnell geht das bissl was du fühlst
bamberger so hören sind doch endlich auf
einen tank schrieb mir wo bin ich denn
hier gelandet nichts zu essen nicht
zutrifft und dann noch dieser duft kopf
dieser primitive ich habe genug gesehen
mir reicht's ich gehe und was ich von
dieser klatsche hier halte das können
sie morgen nachlesen in der schwarz
weißen und zwar schwarz auf weiß
dann wäre sie die oat sie sind ja total
betrunken ja wo ist die sonst so werde
ich nie zu dem münchner party könig
verdammt jetzt brauche ich erst mal ein
bier
dies ist genau das wo sich an fasching
so hasse versaufen auch die amateure